Today I was just awarded the
7th Dan.
I received it from Doshu.
What's very funny is that I had never attended a kagamibiraki,
It was the first time, even though I'm 7th dan, I had never done it.
It might make some people smile  because of my rank and everything ...
It's always intimidating to find yourself in this dojo, in this setup.
And so here I was, very happy...
I couldn't thank all those who helped me progress in my life...
Obviously it's mainly Christian Tissier, so I obviously thank him.
When I started it was of course the Doshu, Osawa [Kisaburo] Sensei,
Masuda Sensei, who no longer participates in these things because I think he is too old.
These are the people who have influenced my aikido a lot
and I thank them for what is happening to me today.
What does this grade represent for you?
It's an important grade obviously.
It's a result of all the work done.
But in fact, beyond that, I started Aikido in Japan
so every time I come back here I feel like I'm going back to a place from my childhood,
and so today being in this dojo, where I worked a lot, where I sweated a lot,
it made me feel warm to find myself in this place for this 7th dan promotion.
It's a big responsibility.
I already have a big responsibility because of the name I carry,
because being named Tissier is not always easy.
Now that I'm a 7th dan, I can't afford to act poorly or speak poorly.
I have to show the way, I have to stay within the ranks somehow.
I didn't expect to reach this level one day, I must say things as they are.
When I started at the Aikikai, I was 15 years old, so when I saw a 1st dan, for me it was already the top.
So to climb the ladder like that and to arrive at this grade today...
I’m not going to say it was unwanted, because obviously everyone wants to get to the grade above,
but I never thought it would happen to me one day,
because I think I'm very close to my students,
I hope in any case that I'm not big headed and that my pupils know it.
This is something very important for me.
In addition, my students were super nice,
it was really very warm.
It really warmed my heart.
From your beginnings to your promotion today, could you describe your relationship with the Hombu?
The grade of 7th Dan is given in the room which serves as the museum of the founder of Aikido.
I was with Dohsu, my daughter was allowed to come in to take a photo.
I had to bow, so I started to kneel,
but the Doshu said to me: "no, don't kneel down"
and he placed himself next to me he showed me what I had to do.
So that made my daughter smile a little, as well as the Dojo-cho, who was there.
It was very nice, after he smiled and he even laughed a little,
because I was not really in the mold compared to what had been planned
But hey, it was very nice, it was very friendly.
And then there are other anecdotes too, for example,
it was during the [1988 International Aikido Federation] congress in Tanabe.
There were local practitioners who weren't violent,
but they were a little bit harsh.
So in the evening I said to Christian, who had not attended the course:
"They're a little rough here."
I raised my right arm and I had five finger marks, bruises,
because we did Ikkyo and they grabbed my arm...
Christian must have told someone, I don't know who, perhaps Yasuno.
The next day, when I arrived at the seminar,
all the uchi deshi came to work with me,
10 minutes and every time it changed, they came to work with me
so that I didn't work with local people and so that I wasn't treated roughly.
So that's it, all of which is to say that it's a big family.
Even if we don't see each other often, there is this link that is there.
Somehow, I feel a a bit like a child of the  Aikikai.
I started here, Doshu has always known me...
because of the fact that Christian Tissier has become very famous.
But even now that we are no longer together, there is still this bond,
which is the bond of Aikido in general, because Aikido is a big family.
So there is always this link that is there.
I know when they say: "Micheline"...
as Yasuno said, I have a reputation at the Aikikai, and when we say Micheline, people know who it is.
So even though some people have never seen me, they know my name.
So that means that somehow, I managed to get
this reputation independently of Christian
Tissier,
my reputation comes from the fact that I trained at the Aikikai...
Because we came back every year for 22 years with Christian,
I trained, I was pushed by the uchi deshi, I didn't give up,
and so it all made me manage to make my own reputation at the Aikikai.
About the IAF, what is it like to be a teacher at the congress now?
It feels strange because actually, since I started at 15,
I attended every congress since 1976,
and it’s true that it’s really strange to be in front of the students,
at the congress, to give a lesson yourself.
My first reaction when I stepped inside was to tell myself:
"Hey, you got old because you're on the other side of the mirror."
And at the same time it was great,
to do a course like the one I did 3 years ago,
where there were almost 700 people on the tatami, it's very impressive.
But again, because I started here in Japan,
Osawa Sensei, who was at the entrance when I came in, said to me:
"Is your heart beating?"
I said, "Yes Sensei, my heart is beating."
He said, "Don't worry, you have a really good Sensei and it's going to be fine."
So that too, those small attentions...
If I hadn't started Aikido in Japan...
I think that the Sensei: Osawa Sensei, Miyamoto Sensei, Yasuno Sensei,
they liked me then and they still like me,
so they are always there to support me, as they did when I was younger.
So it’s also nice to find friends who are there,
with a strong link, so it's good.